one of the really important ways that
the yale school of public health impacts
public health beyond yale is through the
work of our students and alumni as paul
has already shown today we're going to
highlight the work and ideas of five of
our students to give you a sense of the
breadth and future impact of our
students I'm going to take the
opportunity to highlight a little of the
background that feeds the work that each
of them will be presenting in terms of
format I'm going to go ahead and
introduce all five of the presenters in
order and then they will go ahead and
speak one after the other we encourage
you to seek the presenters out following
their talks and talk with them at the
end of the session is we're not going to
be taking questions during their talks
our first speaker Hannah cannock worked
in public health regulation before
coming to Yale in the Environmental
Health Sciences track she's had the
opportunity to study exposure and risk
assessment the combination of course
work and her previous work in public
health regulation has led to her
decision to pursue the regulatory
affairs track at YS pH with an eye to a
future career working in public health
and substance abuse this background is
integrated in her presentation up in
smoke how marijuana legalization affects
us all our second speaker Richard Nygard
took a course on appropriate technology
for the developing world at the Center
for engineering innovation and design as
a junior in Yale College through the
innovation he worked on in that class
cushy baby and the opportunity to
participate fully in the innovation
process rooted has found a passion for
social entrepreneurship in 2014 the
cushy baby team won the throne the thorn
prize for social innovation in help this
past week koshi baby was named one of
two winners of the UNICEF wearables for
good challenge out of 250 applicants
from 46 countries many of you had the
opportunity to hear route sheet last
year as part of the presentation on
entrepreneurship at Yale he'll be
providing an update on the progress of
cushy baby in his talk entitled cushy
baby a wearable platform to bridge the
world's immunization gap Yuna Lee
is our third speaker she worked at the
New York City Health Department as the
special projects coordinator for the
chief operations officer prior to coming
to YS pH for her PhD this gave her a lot
of exposure to how people work in
organizations her PhD course work in
health services research quantitative
methods and classes at the school of
management on organizational behavior
allowed her to bring new insights to her
reflections on those experiences in
healthcare administration the most
pivotal course she took was the
creativity and innovation course at som
where she learned how to encourage
creativity within organizational
settings she will share that passion
with us in her presentation building
creative healthcare organizations for
quality improvement Alex rich brings
years of experience as a military pilot
with committed attention to safety and
efficiency to his new career in public
health he's developing his technical
skills with courses such as database
architecture managing software
development and health care strategy
he's also volunteering with the clinical
redesign team at yale-new Haven Hospital
and helping to plan the Yale center for
biomedical interventional technology
yale-new Haven Hospital healthcare
hackathon in January his commitment to
straightforward workable solutions will
be evident in his presentation on
simplicity in cargo ships and healthcare
our final speaker Laura scrip that you
saw briefly in that video has always
enjoyed math and she wouldn't have
considered majoring in anything else
during college however when she first
started traveling with a medical
anthropologist and gaining international
field experience she wasn't sure her new
passion could be integrated with her
quantitative background at YS pH laura
has learned to do just that and she is
now studying mathematical modeling of
neglected tropical diseases she will
share her experience integrating these
passions in her talk on Ebola math risk
and global health crises Hannah
thank you
we could take a moment to envision a
high-powered attorney a primary care
physician and an elementary school
teacher going home after a long day of
work and instead of pouring a glass of
wine to relax rolling a joint to smoke
this is the reality in states like
Oregon Washington Alaska DC in Colorado
we're not only medical marijuana has
been legalized but retail has as well
and anyone over the age of 21 can walk
into a dispensary and buy marijuana just
like you and I can walk into a liquor
store and buy alcohol and do a
convenience store and buy a pack of
cigarettes in 2012 i graduated from
trinity college and i moved out to
colorado where my parents live i got a
job working as an fda tobacco compliance
specialist I can tell you a whole lot
about that job but I can tell you that
was working really hard to keep Nick
Atene out of the hands of impressionable
teenagers this was kind of a dream job
for me my entire family smokes I grew up
in a house of second-hand smoke and for
those of you who can relate to this
experience you could probably relate to
my personal vendetta against big tobacco
that was 2012 the same year that
amendment 64 was passed with 54.8
percent of voter approval in Colorado
amendment 64 allows for the possession
growth and use of marijuana by private
citizens it also sets up regulation and
taxation of dispensaries but this wasn't
Colorado's first walk on the wild side
medical marijuana had been legal since
2000 Medical dispensaries have been open
since 2009 in fact it was commonly
written that there were more
dispensaries on a denver city block than
there were McDonald's and Starbucks
combined this is Colfax Avenue main
street number if you will we have a
donut shop a tattoo parlor and a
dispensary seems kind of normal right
on january first 2014 retail
dispensaries were able to open and the
state made millions and millions of
dollars in tax revenue all regulated by
the Department of Revenue they're not
the only Bureau in charge of regulating
marijuana policies this last summer I
got to work as the marijuana program
intern at the Colorado Department of
Public Health and Environment which is
tasked with many jobs but most
importantly they review the academic
literature and provide evidence-based
recommendations to the state legislature
with regards to adverse health outcomes
and if there's one thing I learned as an
end as an intern there's a very clear
paucity of high-quality population level
data with regards to adverse health
outcomes and marijuana use you see the
state really wanted to do this long-term
comparison of pre legalization
population users and post legalization
population users they couldn't because
there wasn't baseline data they didn't
know what that population looked like
pre legalization who was using how are
they using what were they using we
didn't know what we do know is that when
you use marijuana especially high doses
often due to accidental overuse we see
things like cyclic vomiting syndrome
anxiety depression psychosis more
fatally we see things like automobile
accidents that not just affect the users
but the public as well especially when
combined with alcohol use this is a huge
problem we've seen an increase in ER
visits hospitalizations poison control
center calls all related to marijuana
use and this is where dose becomes an
important part of the equation dose of
what dose of
dose of THC tetrahydrocannabinol which
is the primary hallucinatory agent in
cannabis this is the chart that shows
the increase in percent THC in cannabis
over time this was released by the
federal government however it doesn't
illustrate what's going on in states
that have legalized because botanists
and states like Colorado are producing
plants that have more along the lines of
23 to 27 percent THD so if you take this
tallest bar here duplicate it and stack
it on itself that's the reality in
states that have legalized what does
this tell us this tells us this is not
the weed your parents are smoking in the
60s and 70s this is a completely new
drug a drug that we don't know a whole
lot about and whenever you introduce a
new drug to to a population there's a
learning curve abuse and this was indeed
the case with marijuana you see we did
such a great job in the 90s teaching
people that cigarettes equal bad smoking
equals bad the naive users of marijuana
people who have never used before or
people who use when they were young and
want to experiment now they want to
avoid smoking all together because
that's what we taught them okay good job
for us but now they're turning to
edibles edibles are cannabis infused
foods and the average they normally come
in like pot brownies or cookies an
average Colorado cookie edible has 100
milligrams of THC in it the recommended
safe dosage is 10 milligrams it's almost
lunch time I know everyone's getting
hungry
so I'm going to show you a picture of a
cookie could you you one tenth of this
cookie probably not right now right what
would happen if a child got a hold of
this cookie it takes a half an hour for
an edible to kick in you eat one of
these cookies you wait 10 minutes
nothing happens so you eat another
cookie in 20 minutes you're feeling the
effects of 20 times the recommended
dosage of THC and you might be feeling
some effects may be different ones than
when I spoke of earlier maybe you have
heart palpitations paranoia maybe you
blacked out who knows don't like cookies
that's okay what do you like swedish
fish you like rice krispie treats soda
pop you name it they make an edible out
of it and the thing about edibles is
that they're marketed produced and sold
in a very familiar fashion and displays
behind the cashier lots of colors also
flavors discreet packaging to me these
edibles look like packs of cigarettes
e-cigarettes those tiny bottles of
alcohol you see at the liquor store if
there's one thing I learned from
regulating tobacco it's that the most
effective laws are the ones that target
big tobacco's ability to appeal to young
too young audiences they have made in
our out of creating new generations of
smokers new generations of users they
call them replacement smokers it would
be naive of us to think that the
marijuana industry won't or already
hasn't succumbed to the same interests
the tobacco has had for almost a century
this is a great opportunity for public
health we can take what we learn from
tobacco apply it to marijuana
legalization this is our chance to not
let history repeat itself I'll leave you
with this we're seeing higher dose
products that are more accessible at
lower prices we're seeing effective
marketing to vulnerable populations and
normalization of use are we ready for
legalization thank you
alright how's everyone doing all right
great I know it's close to lunchtime so
hang in there my name is rich it I'm
here to talk to you guys about khushi
baby because she is a Hindi word it
means happy and our goal at cushy baby
is to have happy and healthy babies what
we're trying to do is we're trying to
make a wearable platform I'll explain
what that is to solve the world's
immunization gap so speaking of the
immunization gap let's talk about this
number five hundred thousand five
hundred thousand kids under the age of
five die every year in india from
vaccine-preventable disease just take a
moment to let that soak in five hundred
thousand kids die from preventable
disease and this is just symptomatic of
something that happens around the world
close to one and a half million children
die and most of these kids are dying in
developing countries for things that we
have solutions for so what does the
government of india doing now they have
a campaign called mission in through the
new sh and you know they're doing this
media campaign telling family is to be
wise immunize make sure your child gets
all 10 vaccines but it's not that simple
as this cartoon tries to portray is not
only do you have to get those first ten
vaccines in that first year of life you
have to get them according to a very
specific times table so why are people
going under immunized or unamused unicef
did a big study in 2009 and they
interviewed over 10,000 mothers and what
they found is that mothers did not feel
the need or do not know about vaccines
as the major reasons why there was under
immunization so people can get under mu
knives because of demand side factors or
supply side factors in this case their
hypothesis is that people just don't
know there's not a high level of
awareness in certain pockets of the
community so what do those pockets of
the community actually look like well in
order to get a better sense you have to
go to the field you have to go to the
far flung last mile villages which have
the lowest rates of immunization in fact
we don't actually know what the rates of
immunization are because there isn't
good data on it so what does that look
like how does a vaccine get to the last
mile
this was the problem that we were sort
of tasked with a year and a half ago at
the Center for engineering innovation in
design I'll tell you the story that I've
come to get a sense of over the past two
summers it starts with a traditional
birth attendant who lives in the village
has to keep track of 10 to 15 mothers
who either pregnant or with infants she
has to go walking ten kilometres a day
reminding them went to come in for
immunizations meanwhile you have a
health worker who gets on his bike he
drives through tough terrain for over
two hours with a vaccine box strapped to
his side the mother has to leave her job
usually on the farm with child in hand
and walk for about an hour through
monsoons or 300 degree plus whether to
arrive at a campsite which really is
like a you know it might be a school
building it might just be a building and
you're really on the patio of that
building and this organized chaos
finally when you get your five minutes
of fame with the health worker you have
to present your health information and
this is something that we're all
familiar with so how does that work you
have a paper card that you're supposed
to hold on to for almost two years
throughout the antenatal care period and
through the period of routine
immunizations if I were to ask you to
hold on to a piece of paper for two
years it's not an easy thing to do
people try they put in the plastic but
ultimately the paper cards are often not
even filled out so that means the health
regress to guess was your child born
before or after the harvest in order to
determine which vaccine to give today
and that's not good enough even if we
are able to make that immunization
possible there's one step that often
goes unfinished that's the step of
documenting the whole event in the first
place everything is written down on
paper which means it's hard for health
officials to know what's going on it's
hard to search people's names the
information is lost we want to get that
information use that information is
important we need to know which kids are
going under immunized we have to know
which specific kids are going under
immunized not just generally in the
state or in the country so what have we
try to do we want to make sure that
everyone owns a digital copy of their
health in the form of a necklace so we
want to replace this card in a sense or
supplement it with a wearable something
that can stay with you something that's
did
goal that acts as an easy touch point to
the health care provider something that
stores your data in a completely
decentralized and offline manner so you
don't have to be connected to the
internet in order to look up someone's
health information you don't to have a
laptop you simply have to scan the
necklace with our app in order to figure
out which vaccines the kid has already
received in which vaccines I need to
give today one other thing I'd like to
talk about is that the necklace has a
black thread and this is important
because we're not simply trying to dump
technology in the hands of these
communities the black thread has a very
important symbolic meaning and these
communities to protect the child from
evil eye or evil spirits so we also have
to think about who's going to adopt that
technology who's going to use that
technology and how can we promote health
seeking behaviors to the actual form of
what we're trying to make the
information eventually will get pushed
up to health officials by using taking
advantage of 2g signal which is actually
of very high penetration in india so
healthcare workers have real-time
analytics location-specific analytics
patient-specific analytics at their
fingertips they can even do things like
call mothers in these communities
reminding them went to come in because
we can collect their phone numbers and
sort of control it in an automated way
that really gets me to sort the last
thing I'd like to talk about which is
we're not just trying to collect data
and that's a huge issue that we're
trying to address we're also trying to
address this earlier issue of generating
demand generating awareness you know
there are many em health projects
electronic health projects that are
trying to collect data we need to go one
step further in order to actually
improve immunization so how are we going
to do that first of all we think the
necklace can act as a social signal like
a LIVESTRONG band for people to start
talking about immunizations they can ask
where did you get that I got about the
immunization camp maybe I should take my
child there we have voiced call
reminders and the local dialect there
are many dialects in India and it's very
important to be able to reach and remind
mother so that way they follow the
appropriate help-seeking behavior we
want to give health care workers a list
of patients that they should expect to
see they travel so far out there and
then they don't know who should come who
shouldn't come they just immunize
whoever comes that's not going to be
good enough we need to have a better
idea of what the true demand is
we need to know how many vaccines we
gave out but also how many times we
couldn't give out a vaccine because the
the vial would have been spoiled or
because the mother didn't want a second
injection we need to think about mothers
and how they're connected in a social
network approach who's going to be
influential in society who can we
recruit or use as a recruitment champion
to bring more mothers in and how can we
target mothers early on during the
antenatal care period so that way their
health seeking behavior can be improved
throughout the first year after birth
these are all things that we're thinking
about their sort of i'm looking at in my
own thesis research and that are going
to be integral to moving this project
forward not just for efficiency but also
for program efficacy i want to take a
moment to talk to thank you all and to
also talk about the progress that we've
had in the last year and a half we
started at the yale center for
engineering innovation in design and we
are now rolled out in over a hundred
villages tracking over a thousand
children with our system we have raised
a lot of money and that is really you
know our success is your success because
you've supported us we've had the
umbrella of support from the yale
community from the cgi deeds to school
of public health yei if you want to
continue to get engaged or involved
please go to khushi baby org k h gu shi
feel free to contact me after i can't
answer any questions right now but i
will be available after to discuss
further and we look forward to your in
your continued feedback and support as
we go from a start-up to scale up and
really try to take this innovation for
public health to bother broader scale
video left why press
cool okay so way my pocket good morning
everyone
I grew up watching my family run a very
special line of nursing homes in
Australia I saw how the smallest actions
on the part of the staff could lead to
huge improvements in patients experience
of care take the example of Tony Tony
was a kitchen server who would carry
plates from the kitchen Tony towered
over patients in wheelchairs and he
empathized that it must feel
dehumanizing to be talked down to all
day so one day Tony knelt down beside
the patients and met them at their eye
level as he spoke to them and place down
their plates it was a moment of
connection compassion and respect that
made all the difference today all 500
staff meet the patients at their eye
level as they speak to them I've
discovered that improving the patient
experience is like this it's the
accumulation of quiet but meaningful
operational changes that matter to
patients in the United States and
throughout the world health care is
undergoing a transformation it's a
reaction to the recognition that our
current systems are just unsustainable
in 2015 the United States will spend one
trillion dollars on hospital care but
only 71 percent of patients would
definitely recommend their hospital
based on their experience the patient
experience is rapidly becoming a top
quality issue humane and empathetic care
is the right thing to do it improves
patient safety and clinical
effectiveness and is now being tied to
Medicare reimbursement so for the first
time not only if the care worked but
also if the care was respectful and
responsive to your needs and values
matters now the two sound like they're
related but they're not the same thing
research has shown that great clinical
care outcomes don't always equal a great
care experience so in health care today
most of the innovations that we see come
from Silicon Valley or from labs which
are great for five
and combating disease but it's just not
the whole story parts of the health care
journey like building trust
relationships and continuity of care
they just can't be solved with a nap
what we need to improve the patient
experience may already be lying within
our healthcare organizations profound
ideas for quality improvement arise
every day from Health Care's front lines
just look at Tony we just have to learn
how to catch them I study the science of
creativity in health care organizations
for my doctoral dissertation at Yale I
would like health care to start thinking
about creativity which is the process of
generating novel and useful ideas in
other industries creativity is used as a
tool for quality improvement and also a
resource to help organizations adapt and
learn health care organizations can
learn to do this too so I was recently
surprised to know that the stars of the
recent Pixar movie inside out almost
didn't make it to the big screen it
turns out that creativity doesn't just
happen it's not some abstract
freewheeling light bulb moment like we
see in the movies creativity results
from organizations being adaptive
collaborative but most of all deliberate
in their choices to nurture and savor
good ideas now Pixar has dominated
animation for 20 years and is always
setting new standards for originality
but the premise behind inside out that a
whole movie could focus on the emotions
of an 11 year old girl was wild even for
their standards so there's a special
place in Pixar where you can pitch new
ideas without fear of looking stupid or
putting your ego on the line they call
it the brain trust the brain trust is a
rotating team of Pixar staff from all
ranks of moviemaking who listen to good
ideas provide honest feedback and then
work for months together to make the
good ideas happen
thanks to the brain trust the writer
with the idea felt safe enough to speak
up and thanks to Pixar the world now
enjoys the fruits of this wonderful idea
Pixar has to deliberately organized for
creativity and they're in a creative
industry so health care may face some
special challenges eliciting creativity
from its frontline staff health care is
ordered we have checklists and we have
rules to reduce risk health care is
hierarchical the right to speak up often
comes with experience and status health
care is complex and its high stakes and
for the professionals inside it can
sometimes feel that they have very
little control over their work and just
little time to be creative so how do we
foster creativity in health care so I
study a real life creative health care
organization in my work there a primary
care system based right here in
Connecticut and they do a lot of work to
address these challenges and honor the
voices of its frontline staff I've been
visiting this organization for three
years and lately i have read hundreds of
pages of meeting minutes because it
turns out that this organization has a
brain trust of its own called the
clinical micro system where frontline
care staff get together weekly and
brainstorm and workout ideas to improve
the patient experience so i've been
extracting creative ideas out of these
minutes and i'll have experts rate than
four level of creativity I'll then
bringing together other sources of data
to start painting the picture of what
makes this organization creative we
surveyed frontline staff so physicians
nurses medical assistants and behavioral
health providers about their experience
of work do you feel like part of a team
do you feel like you can speak up we
then virtually followed them around for
a week and by that I mean that they wore
these super cool electronic social
senses that click every time they speak
to another care member
and these badges give us a sense of
their social networks and how chatty and
social they are at work and finally we
ask patients about their experience of
care so bringing all of this data to
bear allows us to answer questions like
how creative of these ideas what does
the journey look like for a creative
idea of a time a good ideas getting lost
and forgotten or are they evolving and
becoming implemented as innovations who
is creative at work is it the new
recruit with the fresh eyes or is it the
old guard who's been around and seen the
breakdowns and how connected are they
are they having diverse conversations
and being exposed to diverse
perspectives or are they hanging out
with their own kind their own role who
is speaking up at work is it the medical
assistant or the physician and who's
dominating and interrupting
conversations so this work through this
work I hope to uncover what makes
healthcare organizations and how that
relates to outcomes that we really care
about such as a patient experience in
conclusion creative ideas have the
potential to improve the organization
and the experience of care in settings
as diverse as hospitals nursing homes to
in the field healthcare organizations
can organize for creativity and by doing
so we're bridging the gap to a better
patient experience let's reimagine
healthcare as a creative industry great
ideas are just waiting for us to find
them thank
okay we will get you to launch here
shortly I promise I'll be as quick as I
can today I want to tell you a story
about the expansion of one of the most
powerful and potentially dangerous
industries in the history of mankind and
the advancement of the most powerful
tool ever developed by our species and I
want us to view this together through
the lens of one of my favorite concepts
that of simplicity I want you to think
about big complicated systems with
misaligned incentives and the production
of simple solutions that are
person-centered and the impact of that
on society as a whole our story begins
in the middle of the 19th century in
England in small shipping communities
and it starts with a man named Samuel
plimsoll Samuel had a little bit of a
difficult life his father died in early
age and sam went to work to support his
family eventually he built up a coal
speculation business and lost it and was
out on the street and was too proud to
ask for assistance from his friends and
family so what he found was that he
really identified with the generosity
and kindness of the working poor in
England and he built really strong bonds
with those people that he retained even
after he recovered and got himself into
Parliament and became pretty important
in society same who found in his time
with them that for the first time ever
there were a lot of young men
disappearing from these shipping
communities that go out on cargo ships
and never come home and in an era before
Google and Facebook was very difficult
to find that pattern and draw down to
its cause what he found was that for the
first time in the history of shipping it
was possible to over ensure a cargo ship
to ensure it for more money than it was
worth and this was causing some
unethical ship owners to send their
ships out to sea overloaded and over
insured so that if the ship sank in the
middle of the ocean they made good money
because they got the insurance money and
if the ship made it to its destination
they made good money because it got
there with more cargo than it rightfully
should have
so when digging into this problem Sam
was very very tenacious because it was a
very complicated problem he went well
outside his discipline to try to find
the solution he went first to the
shipowners and said hey can you police
your own and they said no because we
don't want to call out any of our people
this is very socially unacceptable to us
so he went to the insurer's and said hey
could you develop some regulation
because it's in your incentive to not
insure ships that are going to sink and
they said no because we've distributed
the cost so much that it cost me less to
pay for a ship that sank than it does to
refuse to pay and lose my reputation as
an insurer same story with the captain's
because for a captain to refuse an
overloaded ship made him a coward who
was unemployable so what Sam came down
to was the person to make the decision
was the individual sailor getting on
board the ship but the problem was that
the system was too complex that sailor
had no way to see if the boat was safe
or not so Sam made some friends who were
naval architects and what he was able to
do was take that big complicated system
with misaligned incentives and lots of
different parties none of whom were
there to protect the individual and
distill thousands of hours of naval
architecture into a single simple symbol
that you could put on the side of a ship
and anyone regardless of their education
level could see if that symbol was below
the waterline that ship is unsafe do not
get on it so after discovering this Sam
got into Parliament and began a ten year
long battle to get this mandated and he
found that he was rebuffed and rebuffed
and rebuff repeatedly because everyone
in the system that was so misaligned had
friends in Parliament and Sam almost got
himself kicked out of parliament in this
fight eventually he wrote a book that
became incredibly popular went to the
people got it forced through and today
if you go to any major commercial
shipping port on the planet you will see
a variation of the plimsoll line Sam
plimsoll by taking an unbelievably
complicated problem and distilling it
into a simple human centered solution
has saved tens of thousands of lives
long past the duration of his own life
it's a big deal I followed my own symbol
into my first career this is my
grandfather this is my grandfather
he was a aerial gunnery instructor in
World War two and that he was my hero
and so I followed his path into being a
military pilot at slu kc-135s and then I
transitioned to flying an airplane about
a tenth that size a little single-engine
you 28 for air force special operations
command and it was the time of my life I
loved it did it for about 10 years
deployed 10 times and on my tenth
deployment two things happen that
changed the course of my life first of
all after 10 deployments and having gone
down for medical reasons once or twice I
found that in my last deployment I was
unable to fly medically about four
different times we couldn't figure out
what the problem was and eventually it
disqualified me from flying status this
was my first real brush with healthcare
I had seen primary care doctors annually
before that but I'd always been pretty
healthy this drove me to a specialist
and what I found was an unbelievably
complicated system with incentives that
didn't always align and communications
that didn't always get the right
information to the decision maker I
found that my specialist who i got to
see after four months of waiting
couldn't always transmit the results of
my tests to my primary care doctor and
when it got there I had to carry paper
to back it up and it was very difficult
for us all to make the right decision so
I see a tremendous opportunity to do the
same kind of simplification thing inside
health care the other thing that
happened was my grandfather passed away
about a week before my last returned
from Afghanistan and what we found
subsequently was that it was driven by a
problem with taking his medication on
time think about that in this country
we've spent hundreds of millions of
dollars developing the right drugs and
hundreds of thousands of dollars
training the right doctors and we did
all that right we got to the 2-yard line
with this thing and we got the
medication onto his counter and the
thing that kept us out of the goal line
was the fact that he had a hard time
knowing what time of day it was when to
take his pills and we didn't find out
about that problem until he was in the
emergency room I believe we can do
better than that and so having thought
about that a lot and having spent you
know a portion of my life doing a very
different kind of mission I I was lucky
enough to be able to fly a mercury
poison baby across
the Pacific to safety at nine tenths the
speed of sound and after that I got to
fly over the top of seals and Rangers as
they assaulted terrorist compounds
making sure that they were safe but the
most important mission of my life so far
is this finding a way to take this
incredibly complicated system and
simplify because every year 125,000
Americans die from prescription
adherence problems this is a problem
that will touch everyone in this room if
it has not already and really all it
needs is to Center the system around the
patient to be able to get the medication
to the patient and to be able to see
every day that lights and buzzers
attract the patient's attention get them
to take the pill on time and if they
don't to close the loop via cellular
communication to either a family member
or care provider simple as that so that
you find out the day that they don't
take the pill instead of the day when
they arrive in the ER it's too late so
that's what I've been working on and
this is one of those days where I very
nearly committed to a ph.d program at
Texas A&M so I love Texas but this is
one of those days where I'm a little bit
happy to not be in Texas this is this is
not a clock but it has a clock in it
this is what I've developed
it's a little bit of an ugly prototype
but it does the thing and so this is
going to be a long battle it might be a
ten-year battle there are a lot of
people trying to do this and I hope that
one of them gets there before me but if
they do not this is what I see is the
solution something simple that takes an
unbelievably complicated problem with
lots of misaligned incentives and
centers it around the patient so we can
get it right the first time every time
thank
aren't you scared friends were asking
well I had crunched the numbers and knew
that as of September fourth there were
1871 cases in Liberia so the crude
probability of any individual catching
the disease in the country was 125th of
a percent no I was not worried about
getting Ebola I got to Monrovia with a
classmate in mid-september of last year
within about eight hours of checking
into the hotel we were due to meet with
the Deputy Minister of Health it was
felt like a really big deal meeting him
I remember going in for the handshake he
graciously smiled but backed slowly away
a series of awkward boughs and fake
elbow bumps ensued there's a no-touch
policy in Liberia Minister nindra
escorted us to a data management meeting
where CDC staff was explaining the
exponential trajectory of the epidemic
curve every day there were more and more
cases and the close contacts of these
cases required follow-up we then sat
down with the head of the Liberian data
management team he said they were having
trouble keeping up with the massive
amounts of contact tracing data would we
be able to help develop an app for that
we went to several their meetings and
the common theme emerged we are
constantly being asked have you heard
about the contact tracing issues so what
is contact tracing it is a way to
intervene and interrupt before nutrients
of transmission begin so a suspected
case develop symptoms since Ebola virus
is transmitted through bodily fluids
people who are in closest contact with
the case are a greatest risk of
developing the disease so in theory
these close contacts could be followed
or traced for a 21-day period so that if
any of them started to develop symptoms
they could be quickly isolated before
transmitting to their own network
of contacts in reality though contact
tracers were documenting all of this
information on forms and paper was
simply piling and piling so you could
imagine how an app would be pretty
appealing and oh my goodness everybody
CDC wh 0 e health they all wanted their
name on this hypothetical app but it was
a pretty complicated undertaking my
classmate and I are not necessarily
traditional graduate students we had
years of international field work
combined and we were not in Liberia as
an academic exercise we were there to do
something and we really wanted to
contribute to the data management
problems with contact tracing so we
first set out to sort solve some of the
ministries server issues we prepared a
PowerPoint slide deck and well first of
all for the server I mean once this
contact tracing app was developed the
data would need to go to a secure and
stable environment so we prepared a
PowerPoint slide deck and we went to
Minister NIN's juez office and we sat
and waited and waited and waited some
more because we wanted to introduce him
to the cloud now Minister Nan's was soon
thereafter returns the favor he
introduced us to dr. Musacchio fula who
is leading the field efforts for the
Liberian team in Montserrat o county and
dr. Faleh talked or told us about his
community based initiative that we now
call cbi so montserrat o county is
divided into twenty two zones there are
212 communities and 190 thousand
households and these households made up
blocks of about 25 homes each so since
there are no formal addresses in Liberia
dr. Faleh was trying to map Montanaro
county out zone by zone he was in
recruiting and training community
members to go door-to-door and collect
simple but essential
information he wanted our help with me
the management now we kind of knew right
then and there dr. Faleh you most
definitely need a nap so we went and we
observed and talked to the boots on the
ground and though that's what dr. Faleh
was calling the community workers he was
hiring and we started this app well I
worked on fine-tuning the logic and the
usability of the front end my classmate
was developing the entire back end and
so with the extraordinary help of
friends and family members back home in
about two weeks time we had a nap we had
a couple dozen phones and I'll admit we
had a paper form but we had a plan for
dealing with it active case finders
would go door-to-door and they would
collect information on these forums
about the number of sick individuals the
number of deaths how many visitors there
were they would take these forms at the
end of each day to a supervisor who
would aggravate it and have one line of
data per block this single sheet of
paper would then go to the monitors and
these were the people with the phones
for the app so we piloted this in the
Caldwell district and we asked people
what they liked what they didn't like
about this form and to be taught the
monitors many of whom had never used a
touchscreen how to use the app it
seriously took about two tries they were
very determined now about this time
there was another epidemic gaining speed
first transmission Tate events were
taking place outside of West Africa in
dallas texas and this other epidemic of
fear and hysteria was growing rapidly
fueled by the media and misinformation
when we returned to the US the crude
probability of any person catching Ebola
in Liberia was one tenth of a percent
but in a few days it became clear that
the probability of course
teen was certain the probability I'd be
confined in my apartment the next day a
hundred percent but you know what let's
go back to Liberia and actually
fast-forward a few weeks Ebola was
everywhere but in a completely different
way the Ebola is real song was playing
on the radio the stop Ebola mural that a
local Monrovia man had painted was
making headlines and local community
members were enforcing no visitor
policies they wanted to kick Ebola out
of their communities now at this time
for the first time since the epidemic
started there were empty beds and
treatment units and people were taking a
cautious sigh of relief doctor flaw was
even able to leave and come visit
internationally to share the lessons he
had learned in the field he visited us
here at Yale to give us an update on CBI
that Caldwell pilot had gone so well
that there were now over 500 5,500
active case finders going door-to-door
to collect information this information
was being aggregated and the data was
being sent real time via app to decision
makers of the Ministry of Health who
could then deploy ambulances contact
tracing teams and burial teams to hot
spots this approach is totally
generalizable active keese active
surveillance could be used to find cases
of any disease from malaria to flu holy
cow now this is why we do public health
so the epidemic in Liberia ended months
ago but CBI has been tailored to now
follow up with Ebola orphans and track
their education needs the app has been
updated to do this and actually another
app is underway to follow the
psychosocial needs of Ebola survivors
and speaking of survivors we're actually
teaming up with smart sustainable to
recruit some female Ebola survivors
they're going to learn basic
shooting skills and actually how to
program and code so that they they can
make their own apps this active
surveillance system will be completely
sustainable at that point so the math is
pretty simple some accessible technology
such as what we developed with the help
of smart sustainable strong coordination
and communicate and active community
engagement as dr. Faleh was able to
accomplish is kind of critical for a
healthier more empowered population so
simply put even in an unprecedented
epidemic it is possible and essential
for your health to effectively become
our health
you